amy schumer got candid about the journey
to her new beach body oh god it's the
best i'm so lucky you read our minds amy
on tuesday the comedian took to
instagram with a transparent update
about undergoing endometriosis and
liposuction surgery sharing these two
photos of her at the beach amy wrote in
the caption quote i feel good finally
it's been a journey and she tagged
medical professionals associated with
liposuction
endometriosis and acupuncture amy added
quote never thought i would do anything
but talk to me after your uterus doesn't
contract for 2.5 years and you turn 40.
so i look in the mirror and i go you're
doing the best you can [ __ ]
the actress got some celeb shout outs in
the comments mindy kalin said quote
healthy sexy happy love it
michelle pfeiffer wrote quote
congratulations and carrie washington
dropped a series of hugs and kisses amy
also posted the pics to her instagram
story with some important numbers in the
captions i think i'm just getting
started and life's life's getting better
and better amy added 40 to this pick she
turned the big 4-0 in june of 2021
and amy let her fans know where she
stands with the scale with this photo
reading quote
170 pounds this update comes after amy
shared her health journey with fans last
year in december she revealed she got
her cheek fillers dissolved she
explained on instagram quote i tried
getting fillers turns out i was already
full
joking the results made her look like
maleficent and in september of 2021 amy
revealed she had her uterus and appendix
removed due to endometriosis so it's the
morning after
my surgery
for
endometriosis amy shared this mirror
selfie from a hospital bathroom and a
video message from her hospital bed
my uterus is out
the doctor found
30
um
spots of endometriosis they removed to
remove my appendix because
um the endometriosis had attacked it in
the caption amy advised her followers
quote if you have really painful periods
you may have endometriosis
meanwhile amy's life as mom is clearly a
source of joy in her life
she shares two-year-old son jean with
husband chris fisher and judging from
her instagram they found plenty of
laughs in parenthood
[Music]